antoine bonjour le président élu joe
biden n'a donc pas encore pris ses
quartiers à la maison blanche et déjà
les relations avec moscou se tendent
mais leurs relations se tendent et les
sujets de discorde sont nombreux joe
biden a promis par exemple de répondre
avec force à la cyberattaque qui a pris
pour cible son pays une cyber attaque
attribuée à la russie
il a aussi reproché à donald trump
d'avoir été de façon générale trop
tendre et trop laxiste avec les
autorités russes vladimir poutine lui
paraît dans une certaine mesure habitués
presque résigné aux difficultés qui
l'attendent
même s'il estime qu'il ne faut pas qu'il
ne faut pas en faire une fixation pour
autant écouter quant au changement
d'autorité aux états unis et l'idée
selon laquelle cela deviendrait plus
compliqué pour nous je ne pense pas je
crois que tout sera comme d'habitude
nous ne devons pas être axée sur cela
ils vont comprendre nous nous risquons
d'être confrontés à certaines
difficultés et surtout à certaines
menaces les anticiper et planifier de
manière appropriée notre travail dans le
domaine économique et dans le
renforcement de nos capacités de défense
et puis il ya les dernières sanctions à
l'encontre de la russie qui ne sont pas
étrangères à ces relations dégradées
entre les deux pays des sanctions prises
entre autres contre des entreprises
russes et chinoises liés au complexe
militaro industriel
de quoi provoquer une réaction du
ministre des affaires étrangères russe
regarder au soccer
bono provost deux tours hd répandue les
états unis mène depuis longtemps une
politique hostile à l'égard de notre
pays c'est bien évidemment il y aura une
réponse il s'agit non seulement de son
caractère réciproque ou asymétriques
mais nous tirerons aussi des conclusions
supplémentaires sur l'ensemble des
relations russo américaines
c'est beaucoup cette nouvelle
manifestation flagrante du mépris des
normes du droit international c'est
moins une fois de plus du fait que les
états unis promouvant
règles qui sont imposés à tous les
autres valeurs sûres
les rapports entre washington et moscou
sont pourtant cruciaux sur de très
nombreux dossiers comme par exemple les
traités de contrôle des armements
stratégiques ou encore le nucléaire
iranien
autant de sujets que joe biden a promis
d'aborder dès le début de son mandat
antoine clairon depuis mousse